This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. In the popular imagination, leaders are visionaries, they are single-minded. Like Morpheus in the Matrix films, they know exactly how to rally the troops when catastrophe looms. This is Zion and we are not afraid! Or take the Wolf of Wall Street in which Leonardo DiCaprio plays a ruthless stock trader. At one point he gives a motivational speech to his sales team. Are you behind on your credit card bills? God, pick up the phone and start dialing.
这里是《Hidden Brain》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。在人们的想象中，领导者都是有远见卓识的人，他们目标明确。就像《黑客帝国》电影里的墨菲斯，当灾难降临时，他非常清楚如何召集部队。这是锡安，我们无所畏惧！或者看看《华尔街之狼》，莱昂纳多·迪卡普里奥在片中饰演一位冷酷无情的股票交易员。在某个时刻，他向销售团队发表了励志演讲。你的信用卡账单逾期了吗？天哪，拿起电话开始拨号吧。
Is your landlord ready to evict you? Good! Pick up the phone and start dialing. Is it land more ready or will fix you? Go pick up the phone and start dialing. I want you to deal with your problems by becoming rich. Yeah! In Hollywood's imagination, leaders often have messianic vision and unshakable conviction. I can't accomplish a f***ing damn thing of any human meaning or worth until we cure ourselves
你的房东准备把你赶出去吗？很好！拿起电话开始拨号。你的土地准备好了吗，还是会修理你？去拿起电话开始拨号吧。我要你们通过变得富有来解决你们的问题。耶！在好莱坞的想象中，领导者往往拥有救世主的愿景和不可动摇的信念。除非我们治愈自己，否则我无法完成任何具有人类意义或价值的事情。
of slavery and end this pestilential war. Especially in the United States, we celebrate certainty and look down on those who express doubt, caution, and hesitation. Over the past few weeks, our YouTube.org series has explored the inner voices that can chip away at our self-confidence. We've looked at how we can narrow or broaden our focus to solve different problems, and how we can use the wisdom of friends, family, even strangers to make better choices for ourselves. Today we conclude the series with an examination of the psychological origins and unforeseen consequences of certainty. And we'll explore the magic that happens when we replace certitude with curiosity.
摆脱奴隶制，结束这场瘟疫般的战争。特别是在美国，我们崇尚确定性，而看不起那些表达怀疑、谨慎和犹豫的人。在过去的几周里，我们的YouTube.org系列节目探讨了那些会削弱我们自信心的内心声音。我们研究了如何缩小或扩大我们的关注点来解决不同的问题，以及如何利用朋友、家人甚至陌生人的智慧来为自己做出更好的选择。今天，我们通过审视确定性的心理起源和不可预见的后果来结束这个系列。我们将探索当用好奇心取代确定性时所产生的魔力。
Adam Grant is an organizational psychologist at the Wharton School. He is the author of Think Again, the power of knowing what you don't know. He is interested in the question of obstinacy. Why do so many of us find it difficult to question our own beliefs and challenge our own views? Adam Grant, welcome to Hidden Brain. Thank you, Shankar. Such a treat to be back here.
亚当·格兰特是沃顿商学院的组织心理学家。他是《重新思考：知道你所不知道的力量》一书的作者。他对固执这个问题很感兴趣。为什么我们这么多人觉得质疑自己的信念和挑战自己的观点很困难？亚当·格兰特，欢迎来到《Hidden Brain》。谢谢你，尚卡尔。能回到这里真是太好了。
On the face of it, if I had known you as a kid, I might not have predicted that you would grow up to write a book about the virtues of humility. As a kid, you say you earned the nickname, Mr. Facts. You were very knowledgeable, but it sounds like you yourself had trouble admitting that you were ever wrong. I think I was a pretty annoying kid. It must have been really unpleasant for my friends, too, because I spent so many hours trading baseball cards. And I'd say, well, this Mark McGuire rookie is not worth what you think it is,
从表面上看，如果我小时候就认识你，我可能不会预料到你长大后会写一本关于谦逊美德的书。你说你小时候得了个绰号叫“事实先生”。你知识渊博，但听起来你自己很难承认自己曾经犯错。我想我小时候是个很烦人的孩子。这对我的朋友来说一定也很不愉快，因为我花了很多时间交换棒球卡。我会说，好吧，这张马克·麦奎尔的新秀卡并不像你想象的那样值钱，
because he only had a 282 batting average in 1989, and I just rattle off these random statistics. And I think most of the time, my friends could care less. And over a couple of years, I learned the hard way that this was not serving me well if I cared about people enjoying interacting with me. And also, if I cared about my own learning, the moment that comes to mind is, I must have been in seventh grade. I think I was 12. My friend Khan was on the phone with me. It was a commercial during a sign-filled. And we got into an argument.
因为他在1989年的打击率只有282，我只是随口说出这些随机的统计数据。我想大多数时候，我的朋友们根本不在乎。几年下来，我痛苦地学到，如果我在乎别人是否喜欢与我互动，这种做法对我没有好处。而且，如果我在乎自己的学习，我想到的那一刻，我一定是在七年级。我想我当时12岁。我的朋友汗正在和我通电话。那是在一个充满标志的节目期间的广告。我们吵了一架。
I don't remember what it was about. And I just refused to give in, even though he had really good proof. And eventually he hung up on me. And I called him back. And I said, did the power go out? Why did the line drop? And he said, I won't talk to you until you admit you're wrong.
我不记得是为了什么。我就是拒绝让步，尽管他有很好的证据。最后他挂断了我的电话。我回拨了过去。我说，是停电了吗？为什么电话断了？他说，除非你承认你错了，否则我不会和你说话。
Yeah. And we had a habit of talking every day. So it was a big moment. And by that point, it was clear that he was right. But I was still having a hard time admitting it. And that bothered me. Adam no longer has a big problem. When it comes to admitting he's wrong,
是的。我们有每天交谈的习惯。所以那是一个重要的时刻。到那时，很明显他是对的。但我仍然很难承认这一点。这困扰着我。亚当在承认自己错误方面不再有大问题，
but he does still suffer from a related problem. He finds it hard to challenge other people when they do or say something wrong. Well, I think some of this stems from my personality. I'm a pretty agreeable person. So agreeableness is one of the major dimensions of personality around the world. We think of agreeable people as warm, friendly, polite, welcoming, Canadian,
但他仍然受到一个相关问题的困扰。当别人做错事或说错话时，他发现很难去挑战他们。嗯，我认为这部分源于我的个性。我是一个相当随和的人。所以随和是世界各地人格的主要维度之一。我们认为随和的人是热情、友好、礼貌、好客、加拿大人，
and disagreeable people tend to be more critical, skeptical, and challenging. And they're also statistically overrepresented among engineers and lawyers. And as long as I can remember, I've been agreeable. And it's weird because on the one hand, I hated admitting I was wrong and I was extremely stubborn. But on the other hand, I really liked harmony
而不随和的人往往更具批判性、怀疑性和挑战性。而且在统计学上，他们在工程师和律师中占比过高。只要我记事起，我就一直很随和。这很奇怪，因为一方面，我讨厌承认自己错了，而且我非常固执。但另一方面，我真的很喜欢和谐，
and I wanted to get along with other people. And I can think of multiple situations where I've been sitting in a new bird or a lift, and the air conditioning is just blasting. And it's just too uncomfortable to ask the driver to turn it down because it's not my car. And so I'll just sit there with my teeth chattering until the ride is over. And being agreeable seems like a good thing, but you also point out in the book that it can come with a downside.
我想和别人相处融洽。我能想到很多次我坐在优步或Lyft车里，空调开得很大。但要求司机调小一点太不舒服了，因为那不是我的车。所以我只能坐在那里，牙齿打颤，直到行程结束。随和似乎是一件好事，但你在书中也指出，它可能伴随着负面影响。
Yeah, I think like everything else in life, it has trade-offs. So on the one hand, agreeable people create a lot of harmony. They tend to get along with other people. They're constantly encouraging. But if you look at the data on leadership effectiveness, one of the things you see is highly agreeable people tend to be worse at leading organizations and teams than people who are somewhere in the middle of that spectrum. And the risk is that sometimes they're too nice,
是的，我认为就像生活中的其他事情一样，它有权衡。一方面，随和的人创造了很多和谐。他们倾向于与他人相处融洽。他们总是给予鼓励。但如果你看看关于领导效能的数据，你会发现的一件事是，高度随和的人在领导组织和团队方面往往比那些处于该光谱中间的人表现更差。风险在于，有时他们太好、
they're too polite, they say yes to everything, and they don't challenge people enough. And I've felt that, we see that in negotiations too, where agreeable people are really prone to what's called agreement bias, cleverly, where you come to the table, somebody offers you a terrible deal, but you hate the idea of saying no. And so you say yes to something that's not in your best interest. Being agreeable and wanting to be seen as agreeable are only two of the drivers behind our reluctance to second-guess ourselves and second-guess others.
太礼貌，对什么都说好，而且他们对人的挑战不够。我也感受到了这一点，我们在谈判中也看到了这一点，随和的人真的很容易产生所谓的“协议偏见”，聪明地，当你来到谈判桌前，有人给你一个糟糕的交易，但你讨厌说不的想法。所以你对一些不符合你最大利益的事情说了是。随和以及想要被视为随和，只是我们不愿重新审视自己和重新审视他人的两个驱动因素。
Another source of the problem has to do with a popular notion about the risks of changing one's mind. If you're a student who takes multiple choice tests or if you've watched TV quiz shows like who wants to be a millionaire where you're given four possible answers to each question and have to pick the right one. You have likely experienced the first instinct fallacy. It's one of the most interesting findings in the psychology of being a student. It takes back to an experience we all had growing up. I remember my mom telling me, if you're unsure of an answer on a test, go with your gut. Go with your first instinct. And yet, if you look at the research, if you do go with your gut
问题的另一个来源与关于改变主意的风险的流行观念有关。如果你是一个参加多项选择题考试的学生，或者你看过像《谁想成为百万富翁》这样的电视问答节目，每道题给你四个可能的答案，你必须选出正确的一个。你可能经历过“第一直觉谬误”。这是学生心理学中最有趣的发现之一。它追溯到我们成长过程中都有过的经历。我记得我妈妈告诉我，如果你在考试中对答案不确定，就跟着你的直觉走。跟着你的第一直觉走。然而，如果你看看研究，如果你真的跟着你的直觉走，
versus you second guess your first instinct, which is better. And on average, the vast majority of students who reject their gut, they actually improve their scores on average. And so there's a fallacy that your first thoughts are your best thoughts. A lot of times intuition is just subconscious pattern recognition. And the patterns that you're recognizing from the past may not be relevant to the problem you're solving right now in the present. And so you don't want to trust your gut, you want to test your gut. And even when you tell people about this evidence, they are still reluctant to rethink their first answer.
与你重新审视你的第一直觉相比，哪个更好？平均而言，绝大多数拒绝直觉的学生，他们的分数实际上平均有所提高。所以有一种谬论，认为你的第一想法就是你最好的想法。很多时候，直觉只是潜意识的模式识别。而你从过去识别出的模式可能与你现在正在解决的问题无关。所以你不想相信你的直觉，你想测试你的直觉。即使你告诉人们这些证据，他们仍然不愿意重新思考他们的第一个答案。
I wonder if some of this has to do with the role of regret. If I have a first instinct, a first answer, and I'm wrong about it, I'm going to experience some regret. But if I come up with an answer, and then I switch to the wrong answer, and it turned out my first answer was actually correct, presumably I would experience greater regret now because I had the sense, you know, I actually had the right answer and I foolishly went and changed my mind. That is such an eloquent summary of what a number of psychologists have argued and found. That the regret, the pain of having had the right answer and then undone it is much greater than the pain of sticking with what you thought was the right answer, even though it was wrong.
我想知道这是否与遗憾的作用有关。如果我有一个第一直觉，一个第一个答案，而我错了，我会经历一些遗憾。但如果我想出一个答案，然后我切换到错误的答案，结果发现我的第一个答案实际上是正确的，大概我现在会经历更大的遗憾，因为我有这种感觉，你知道，我实际上有正确的答案，但我愚蠢地去改变了主意。这是对许多心理学家所争论和发现的内容的极其雄辩的总结。即拥有正确答案然后又撤销它的遗憾和痛苦，远大于坚持你认为正确但实际上错误的答案的痛苦。
So stubbornness and obstinacy and the first instinct fallacy affect not just our personal lives, but they also affect things on a much bigger scale. Can you tell me the story of the meteoric rise and fall of Blackberry, Adam? Sure. The beloved Blackberry. I still miss my Blackberry. The keyboard in particular. I wish the iPhone had that. You too? Yes, me too. I'm so glad I'm not alone. Maybe one day. So the Blackberry obviously was a complete rethinking of the way that we communicate. And the Blackberry starts out as a two-way pager, and this brilliant scientist engineer, Mike Lazaridis, figures out that they could actually use this device for work emails. So they launch it, it skyrockets in popularity.
所以固执、顽固和第一直觉谬误不仅影响我们的个人生活，也影响更大规模的事情。亚当，你能告诉我黑莓手机迅速崛起和衰落的故事吗？当然。深受喜爱的黑莓。我仍然怀念我的黑莓。特别是键盘。我希望iPhone也有那个。你也一样？是的，我也是。我很高兴我不是一个人。也许有一天。所以黑莓显然是对我们沟通方式的一次彻底重新思考。黑莓最初是一个双向寻呼机，这位天才科学家工程师迈克·拉扎里迪斯发现他们实际上可以利用这个设备进行工作邮件。于是他们推出了它，它的人气飙升。
I think we can both remember a time when basically everyone you knew had a blackberry and they just dominated the market. And then blackberry fell apart because Mike and his colleagues were unwilling to rethink the very things that had made blackberry great. It's this stuff right here. They all have these keyboards that are there whether you need them or not to be there. But what we're gonna do is get rid of all these buttons and just make a giant screen. A giant screen.
我想我们都能记得一个基本上你认识的每个人都有黑莓手机的时代，它们统治了市场。然后黑莓分崩离析，因为迈克和他的同事们不愿意重新思考那些让黑莓变得伟大的东西。就是这些东西。它们都有这些键盘，无论你是否需要它们都在那里。但我们要做的就是去掉所有这些按钮，只做一个巨大的屏幕。一个巨大的屏幕。
They could not wrap their minds around the idea that people would want a touchscreen. And as late as 2008, 2009, 2010, 2011, when the iPhone has exploded in popularity, they're still having arguments about with Mike as co-founder and co-CEO saying, well, you know, I get this holding up his blackberry and his keyboard. And then the iPhone looking at that and saying, I don't get this. And they just got locked into the set of assumptions that what people wanted out of a blackberry was a device for basically working hell
他们无法理解人们会想要触摸屏的想法。直到2008年、2009年、2010年、2011年，当iPhone人气爆发时，他们仍然在争论，迈克作为联合创始人和联席CEO说，嗯，你知道，我明白了，举起他的黑莓和键盘。然后iPhone看着那个说，我不明白这个。他们只是被锁定在了一套假设中，即人们想要黑莓的是一个基本上用于工作的设备，
as opposed to essentially a computer in your pocket for home entertainment. Right. And they really missed that opportunity to think again. Our reluctance to think again can have even bigger stakes. In the 1980s, NASA downplayed a brewing problem in the spacecraft Challenger. Since the spacecraft had completed many missions, officials assumed it was safe. But in January 1986, the spacecraft exploded moments after liftoff, killing seven astronauts on board. We have a report from the flight dynamics officer that the vehicle has exploded.
而不是本质上是一个口袋里的家庭娱乐电脑。对。他们真的错过了那个重新思考的机会。我们不愿重新思考可能会有更大的赌注。在20世纪80年代，美国国家航空航天局（NASA）淡化了挑战者号航天飞机的一个酝酿中的问题。由于航天飞机已经完成了许多任务，官员们认为它是安全的。但在1986年1月，航天飞机在升空后不久爆炸，导致机上七名宇航员丧生。我们收到飞行动力学官员的报告，称飞行器已经爆炸。
Flight director confirms that. We are out looking at checking with the recovery forces to see what can be done at this point. Or take the US war in Iraq, where President George W. Bush and his colleagues fail to rethink their views after their initial rosy expectations of the war. We will, in fact, be greeted as liberators. Fail to materialize. Adam Sites, another tragedy. The Vietnam War.
飞行主管证实了这一点。我们正在查看并与救援部队核实，看看此时能做些什么。或者以美国在伊拉克的战争为例，乔治·W·布什总统和他的同事们在战争初期乐观的期望落空后，未能重新思考他们的观点。我们实际上会受到解放者的欢迎。未能实现。亚当提到了另一个悲剧。越南战争。
In the early 1960s, diplomat George Ball warned President John F. Kennedy and then President Lyndon Johnson about the risks of entering and escalating the war. He foresaw that if the United States went forward with the war, leaders would later have trouble rethinking their position. It's chilling. Basically, he writes this at the early phase decision of, should we even enter the Vietnam or not? He's an undersecretary at the time. It was a difficult time because as time went on, I found myself more and more isolated
在20世纪60年代初，外交官乔治·鲍尔警告约翰·F·肯尼迪总统和后来的林登·约翰逊总统进入并升级战争的风险。他预见到，如果美国继续进行战争，领导人以后将难以重新思考他们的立场。这令人不寒而栗。基本上，他在关于我们是否应该进入越南的早期决策阶段写下了这一点。他当时是副国务卿。那是一段困难的时期，因为随着时间的推移，我发现自己越来越孤立，
because I was the only one that was urging this kind of a policy. And he basically says, look, what I'm afraid it's going to happen is that we're going to send some initial troops to war and people are going to die. And then we've sent our own people to die. That can't have been for nothing. And so then we're going to have to send more people and invest more resources. And we're going to get trapped in this escalation of commitment to a war that didn't need to be fought in the first place. And my understanding is most historians and political scientists now would tell you
因为我是唯一一个敦促这种政策的人。他基本上说，看，我担心会发生的是，我们将派遣一些最初的部队去打仗，人们会死去。然后我们派出了我们自己的人去死。那不可能白白牺牲。所以我们必须派遣更多的人，投入更多的资源。我们将陷入一场本不需要打的战争的升级承诺中。据我了解，大多数历史学家和政治学家现在会告诉你，
that's exactly what happened. When we come back, we look at why rethinking is psychologically painful and how to help ourselves and others overcome this pain. You're listening to Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. Psychologist Adam Grant is the author of Think Again, a book about the virtues of rethinking oppositions. We've seen how not being open to rethinking our beliefs can have major consequences in our personal,
这正是发生的事情。回来后，我们将看看为什么重新思考在心理上是痛苦的，以及如何帮助自己和他人克服这种痛苦。你正在收听《Hidden Brain》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。心理学家亚当·格兰特是《重新思考》的作者，这是一本关于重新思考对立面美德的书。我们已经看到，不对重新思考我们的信念持开放态度会在我们的个人、
professional, and political lives. Adam, I want to talk about some of the drivers of obstinacy in our lives. I know that you're a fan of the TV show Seinfeld and there's a famous scene which features a restaurant owner who is called the soup Nazi. No soup for you! He makes great soup, but he cannot tolerate the slightest criticism or deviation from the script. I want to play you a short clip where the character Elaine visits the soup Nazi.
职业和政治生活中产生重大后果。亚当，我想谈谈我们生活中固执的一些驱动因素。我知道你是电视节目《宋飞正传》的粉丝，有一个著名的场景，特色是一位被称为“汤纳粹”的餐馆老板。没有汤给你！他做的汤很好，但他不能容忍对剧本的丝毫批评或偏离。我想给你播放一小段视频，角色伊莱恩拜访了汤纳粹。
One mulligatani and what is that right there? Is that lima bean? Yes. Never been a big fan. Um, what is that right there? Is that lime mabe? Yes. Never been a big fan. Um, you know what? Does anyone ever tell you exactly like Al Pacino? You know a son of a woman?
一份闷炖汤，那是什么？那是利马豆吗？是的。从来都不是大粉丝。嗯，那是什么？那是利马豆吗？是的。从来都不是大粉丝。嗯，你知道吗？有人告诉过你吗，就像阿尔·帕西诺？你知道一个女人的儿子吗？
Whoah! Whoah! Very good. Very good. You know something? No soup for you! Come back one year! So the soup Nazi illustrates something that you talk about Adam, the difference between relationship conflict and task conflict.
哇！哇！非常好。非常好。你知道吗？没有汤给你！一年后再来！所以汤纳粹说明了你谈到的一些事情，亚当，关系冲突和任务冲突之间的区别。
What is this difference? I'm suddenly craving some mulgatani, but we'll get back to that. Let's talk about task and relationship conflict. Most of us, especially those of us who are agreeable, when we think about conflict, we're thinking about relationship conflict. That's the personal, emotional, I think you're a terrible person and my life would be better if I never had to interact with you. Kind of clashed that a lot of us run into.
这种区别是什么？我突然渴望喝点闷炖汤，但我们会回到那个话题。让我们谈谈任务冲突和关系冲突。我们大多数人，特别是我们这些随和的人，当我们想到冲突时，我们想到的是关系冲突。那是私人的、情绪化的，我认为你是一个糟糕的人，如果我永远不必与你互动，我的生活会更好。我们很多人遇到的那种冲突。
There's another kind of conflict though that a lot of us run into. There's another kind of conflict, though, that an organizational psychologist named Eddie Jen and her colleagues have studied task conflict. I mean, it's the idea of debating about different opinions and perspectives. It's potentially constructive because it's actually about trying to get to the truth. It's not personal, it's not emotional. We're not trying to beat up the other person. We're not feeling like we're being attacked. We're trying to hash out or sort out different views
不过，我们很多人还会遇到另一种冲突。不过，还有另一种冲突，一位名叫埃迪·詹的组织心理学家和她的同事们研究了任务冲突。我的意思是，这是关于辩论不同意见和观点的想法。它具有潜在的建设性，因为它实际上是关于试图找到真相。这不是私人的，不是情绪化的。我们不是试图打击对方。我们不觉得我们受到了攻击。我们试图通过，
through what might be a feisty conversation, but it's intellectual. And I think one of the biggest problems that the soup Nazi had is he could not have a task conflict without it becoming relationship conflict. The moment that you object to his line or that you don't follow his rules, he takes it very personally and bans you from his soup oasis. Is that how you interpret it as well? That's exactly how I interpreted it. I mean, Elaine has many problems as a character, of course,
可能是一场激烈的对话来梳理或理清不同的观点，但它是理性的。我认为汤纳粹最大的问题之一是他无法进行任务冲突而不让它变成关系冲突。当你反对他的台词或你不遵守他的规则的那一刻，他会非常个人化地对待它，并把你从他的汤绿洲中驱逐出去。你也是这样解读的吗？我完全是这样解读的。我的意思是，伊莱恩作为一个角色当然有很多问题，
but the fact that she's basically saying she's not a fan of lima beans, that is not necessarily a reflection on the super nazi's character. It just means that there's a customer who doesn't like something that you made it. It's not a big deal, but he can't take a criticism or a disagreement as just saying, all right,
但她基本上说她不是利马豆的粉丝，这并不一定是对汤纳粹性格的反映。这只是意味着有一个顾客不喜欢你做的东西。这不是什么大不了的事，但他不能把批评或分歧仅仅看作是说，好吧，
someone has a different opinion than I do. He has to take everything personally. And Adam, you've surveyed teams of workers in Silicon Valley about conflict and examine which groups perform well and which ones don't. And you found that the way they handle task conflict and relationship conflict is often behind successful teams and unsuccessful teams. Can you explain to me what you found? Yeah, I think the mistake that a lot of people make is they assume that less conflict is better.
有人有和我不同的意见。他必须把一切都个人化。亚当，你调查了硅谷的工人团队关于冲突的情况，并检查了哪些群体表现良好，哪些群体表现不佳。你发现他们处理任务冲突和关系冲突的方式往往是成功团队和不成功团队背后的原因。你能向我解释一下你发现了什么吗？是的，我认为很多人犯的错误是他们假设冲突越少越好。
That if you want to build a successful collaboration or a great team, then you want to minimize the amount of tension you have. But as some researchers have argued based on a lot of evidence, the absence of conflict is not harmony, it's apathy. If you're in a group where people never disagree, the only way that could really happen is if people don't care enough to speak their minds. And so in order to get to wise decisions,
如果你想建立一个成功的合作或一个伟大的团队，那么你想尽量减少你所拥有的紧张感。但正如一些研究人员基于大量证据所争论的那样，没有冲突不是和谐，而是冷漠。如果你在一个人们从不分歧的群体中，这真正发生的唯一方式是如果人们不够关心而不敢说出自己的想法。所以为了做出明智的决定，
creative solutions, we need to hear a variety of perspectives, we need diversity of thought. And task conflict is one of the ways that we get there. By saying, you know what? I think we actually don't agree on what the vision for our company should be or what our strategy should be or how to design this product. And so let's hash that out.
创造性的解决方案，我们需要听到各种各样的观点，我们需要思想的多样性。而任务冲突是我们达到这一目标的方式之一。通过说，你知道吗？我认为我们实际上在公司的愿景应该是什么，或者我们的战略应该是什么，或者如何设计这个产品上没有达成一致。所以让我们把它理清楚。
And I don't think we do that enough. So in the study that I did, I tracked team performance over a number of months. And I surveyed people in teams on how often they were having relationship conflict as well as task conflict. Even if they agreed on nothing else, they agreed on what kind of conflict they were having and how much of it. And it turned out in the failed groups, they tended to have a lot more relationship conflict than task conflict, especially early on. They were so busy disliking each other that they didn't really have substantive debates until about halfway through the lifecycle of their project, and by then it was almost
我不认为我们做得足够多。所以在我的研究中，我跟踪了几个月的团队表现。我调查了团队中的人们，询问他们发生关系冲突和任务冲突的频率。即使他们在其他任何事情上都没有达成一致，他们也同意他们正在经历什么样的冲突以及程度如何。结果发现，在失败的群体中，他们往往比任务冲突有更多的关系冲突，特别是在早期。他们太忙于互相厌恶，以至于在项目生命周期的一半之前，他们并没有真正进行实质性的辩论，到那时几乎
too late to change course. Whereas in the high-performing groups, they started out with very little relationship conflict and plenty of task conflict saying, look, before we design a product, we really want to get all the ideas on the table about how we might do it or what it might before. And then once they sorted those out, they were able to really focus and align around what their common mission was and they were able then over time to say okay as different issues crop up that we disagree on we're going to have another debate and we're going to hear each other's views again
太晚了，无法改变航向。而在高绩效群体中，他们开始时关系冲突很少，任务冲突很多，说，看，在我们设计产品之前，我们真的想把关于我们如何做它或它可能是什么的所有想法都摆在桌面上。然后一旦他们理清了这些，他们就能够真正专注于他们的共同使命并保持一致，然后他们随着时间的推移能够说，好吧，随着我们不同意的不同问题的出现，我们将进行另一场辩论，我们将再次听到彼此的观点，
and that ultimately gave them a better shot at working on something that was really promising and you know and there are examples of leaders who basically basically model what it's like to have task conflict without relationship conflict. I was thinking of something that President Obama said some years ago when he invited someone he disagreed with to play a prominent role in his administration. We're not going to agree on every single issue, but what we have to do is to be able to create an atmosphere where we can disagree without being disagreeable and then focus on those things
这最终让他们有更好的机会去从事一些真正有希望的事情，而且，你知道，有一些领导者的例子，他们基本上模拟了在没有关系冲突的情况下进行任务冲突是什么样的。我想到奥巴马总统几年前说的一句话，当时他邀请了一个他不同意的人在他的政府中发挥重要作用。我们不会在每一个问题上都达成一致，但我们必须做的是能够创造一种氛围，让我们可以在不变得令人不快的情况下产生分歧，然后专注于那些，
that we hold in common as Americans. To disagree without being disagreeable, I think many of us forget this lesson at him. We think that if someone else is wrong, our job is just to correct them, how we correct them is unimportant. Yeah, I think that's such a common mistake in communication. We think it's the message that matters, but so often, whether somebody's willing to hear a message depends on who's saying it,
我们作为美国人共同持有的东西。在不变得令人不快的情况下产生分歧，我想我们很多人忘记了这个教训，亚当。我们认为如果别人错了，我们的工作只是纠正他们，我们如何纠正他们并不重要。是的，我认为这是沟通中一个非常常见的错误。我们认为重要的是信息，但通常情况下，某人是否愿意听到信息取决于谁在说，
why it's being said, and how it's being delivered. And I cannot tell you, Shankar, the number of times that I have rejected useful criticism because I didn't trust the person who was giving it to me, or they delivered it in a way that I found disrespectful or offensive. And that was a missed opportunity for both of us. Not all of us listen to useful feedback, even when it's presented clearly and without ranker. That's because we confuse challenges to our views with threats to our ego. There's a term that I love for this which comes out of psychology.
为什么这么说，以及它是如何传递的。尚卡尔，我无法告诉你，有多少次我拒绝了有用的批评，因为我不信任给我批评的人，或者他们以一种我发现不尊重或冒犯的方式传递了它。这对我们俩来说都是一个错失的机会。并非我们所有人都听取有用的反馈，即使它被清晰且没有怨恨地呈现出来。这是因为我们将对我们观点的挑战与对我们自我的威胁混淆了。我喜欢心理学中关于这一点的一个术语。
It's originally a Tony Greenwald's term. It's the totalitarian ego. And the idea is that all of us have an inner dictator policing our thoughts. And the dictator's job is to keep out threatening information much like Kim Jong-un would control the press in North Korea. And when your core belief surattacks, the interdictator comes in and rescues you with mental armor and activates confirmation bias where you only see what you expected to see all along, triggers desirability bias, where you only see
它最初是托尼·格林沃尔德的术语。它是“极权自我”。这个想法是，我们所有人都有一个内在的独裁者在监管我们的思想。独裁者的工作是像金正恩控制朝鲜媒体一样，把威胁性的信息挡在外面。当你的核心信念受到攻击时，内在独裁者就会介入，用心理盔甲拯救你，并激活确认偏见，让你只看到你一直期望看到的东西，触发合意性偏见，让你只看到，
what you wanted to see all along, and you can feel like you're not under threat after all. and you can feel like you're not under threat after all. You can see the totalitarian ego at work in a study conducted some years ago by researchers in Australia. The asked volunteers to think of a time when they did something wrong and apologized for it and to also think about a time when they did something wrong and did not apologize for it. Research at Tyler Rocky Moto explains what they found. When you refuse to apologize, it actually makes you feel more empowered. That power and control seems to translate into greater feelings of self-worth.
你一直想看到的东西，你可能会觉得你毕竟没有受到威胁。你可以在澳大利亚研究人员几年前进行的一项研究中看到极权自我发挥作用。他们要求志愿者想出一个他们做错事并道歉的时间，以及想出一个他们做错事但没有道歉的时间。研究人员泰勒·洛基·莫托解释了他们的发现。当你拒绝道歉时，它实际上让你感到更有力量。那种权力和控制似乎转化为更强的自我价值感。
And in some ways, the sounds like the inner dictator, when we apologize in some ways, we are disarming ourselves and when we refuse to apologize in some ways, we are disarming ourselves, and when we refuse to apologize in some ways, we are mounting a form of emotional self-defense. Yeah, sadly, staying attached to our wrong convictions makes us feel strong. And psychologists have also found for decades that the act of resisting influence is that the act of resisting influence only further fortifies our convictions, because we can, we basically get inoculated against future attacks. We have all of our defenses ready, and we end up sealing our beliefs in an ever more impenetrable fortress.
在某些方面，这听起来像内在独裁者，当我们道歉时，在某些方面，我们是在解除自己的武装，而当我们拒绝道歉时，在某些方面，我们是在进行一种情感上的自我防御。是的，可悲的是，坚持我们错误的信念让我们感到强大。心理学家几十年来也发现，抵制影响的行为，抵制影响的行为只会进一步巩固我们的信念，因为我们可以，我们基本上对未来的攻击产生了免疫力。我们准备好了所有的防御措施，最终把我们的信念封存在一个更加坚不可摧的堡垒中。
We've talked about a number of different drivers of obscenity and stubbornness, our inability to question our own beliefs. I want to talk a moment about the role of identity and stereotypes. Can you talk about how these things are loyalty to different groups, our membership in different tribes? Can keep us in some ways from challenging, you know, dearly held beliefs or cherished beliefs, and in some ways keep us from rethinking our views. Yeah, so I have a brilliant colleague, Phil Tetlock, who wrote a paper about how almost every decision you've ever made, almost every opinion you've ever formed,
我们谈到了固执和顽固的许多不同驱动因素，我们无法质疑自己的信念。我想花点时间谈谈身份和刻板印象的作用。你能谈谈这些东西，对不同群体的忠诚，我们在不同部落中的成员身份，如何在某些方面阻止我们挑战，你知道，珍视的信念或珍视的观点，并在某些方面阻止我们重新思考我们的观点吗？是的，我有一位出色的同事，菲尔·泰特洛克，他写了一篇关于你做过的几乎每一个决定，你形成的几乎每一个观点，
is influenced by your relationship to the people around you and by the groups that you're part of, and the identities that you hold About who you are in the social world and what Phil observed is we often spend time thinking like preachers prosecutors and politicians preaching is basically Defending a set of sacred beliefs and saying look I the truth, my job is to proselytize it.
是如何受到你周围人的关系以及你所属的群体，以及你所持有的关于你在社会世界中是谁以及你是什么的身份的影响。菲尔观察到的是，我们经常花时间像传教士、检察官和政客一样思考。传教士基本上是在捍卫一套神圣的信念，并说，看，我拥有真理，我的工作是传教。
I just don't make any difference if the churches today have stopped preaching on hell. If the preachers don't preach on hell, it is still a place that you must deal with one day. Prosecuting is the reverse. It's saying, okay, my job is to prove you wrong and win my case with the best argument. For this man to skirt, financial and moral responsibility because he found a scusy lawyer and a scusier
如果今天的教堂停止传教地狱，那也没什么区别。如果传教士不传教地狱，它仍然是你有一天必须面对的地方。起诉是相反的。它是说，好吧，我的工作是证明你错了，并用最好的论点赢得我的案子。为了让这个人逃避，经济和道德责任，因为他找到了一个狡猾的律师和一个更狡猾的，
shrink to pronounce him disabled, for for this man to waltz into a court and get an order saying that this woman was never married when she let an exemplary married life, how dare you live? And any time we're part of a group that has strong beliefs, it's pretty unlikely that we're gonna rethink any opinions or decisions as we get into preacher or prosecutor mode because we already know. I already know. I'm right and you're wrong. We're a little more flexible when we shift into politician mode. Look at this.
心理医生宣布他残疾，为了让这个人走进法庭并获得一项命令，说这个女人从未结婚，而她过着模范的婚姻生活，你怎么敢活下去？任何时候，只要我们是拥有强烈信念的群体的一部分，当我们进入传教士或检察官模式时，我们就不太可能重新思考任何观点或决定，因为我们已经知道了。我已经知道了。我是对的，你是错的。当我们切换到政客模式时，我们会稍微灵活一点。看看这个。
What is it? They're calling you the no BSVP. Damn right there. I mean, I lied and everything, but it sounded true at least. Because when you're thinking like a politician, what you're trying to do is get the approval of an audience that you care about. And so you might be campaigning and lobbying
那是什么？他们叫你“无废话副总统”。该死，那是对的。我的意思是，我撒了谎，什么都说了，但至少听起来是真的。因为当你像政客一样思考时，你试图做的是获得你在乎的听众的认可。所以你可能在竞选和游说，
and sometimes that means adjusting and flexing at least what you say you believe in order to fit in and win them over. The problem is that we're doing it because we want to prove our allegiance to a tribe, not because we're trying to get closer to the truth. Coming up, strategies to help us rethink our own views and how to help others reconsider their cherished opinions. You're listening to Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. University of Pennsylvania's psychologist, Adam Grant, has written a book about
有时这意味着调整和灵活，至少是你声称相信的东西，以便融入并赢得他们。问题在于我们这样做是因为我们想证明我们对部落的忠诚，而不是因为我们试图更接近真相。接下来，帮助我们重新思考自己观点的策略，以及如何帮助他人重新考虑他们珍视的观点。你正在收听《Hidden Brain》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。宾夕法尼亚大学的心理学家亚当·格兰特写了一本书，关于，
the power of searching for the flaws in our own beliefs and arguments, of challenging deeply health views. Many of us have trouble doing this, and the echo chambers that surround us usually don't reward us for being reflective and adaptable. But history shows that if we check out personal egos, we can make important discoveries. Adam, you tell the story of Orville and Wilba Wright, the brothers who invented the first successful airplane. Can you describe that relationship to me and how it bears on the conversation we're having? Of all the moments in history that I would love to witness, I think watching the Wright Brothers argue would be pretty high on my list. So if you look at the history of what the Wright Brothers created together, it seemed like they were constantly in sync. They created their own printing press together, they ran their own bicycle shop, they made their own bikes together,
寻找我们自己信念和论点中的缺陷，挑战根深蒂固的观点的力量。我们很多人在做这件事时有困难，而围绕我们的回声室通常不会奖励我们的反思和适应能力。但历史表明，如果我们检查个人自我，我们可以做出重要的发现。亚当，你讲述了奥维尔和威尔伯·莱特兄弟的故事，他们发明了第一架成功的飞机。你能向我描述一下那种关系，以及它与我们正在进行的对话有什么关系吗？在历史上我最想见证的所有时刻中，我想观看莱特兄弟争论会排在我的名单前列。所以如果你看看莱特兄弟共同创造的历史，看起来他们总是同步的。他们一起创建了自己的印刷机，他们经营自己的自行车店，他们一起制造自己的自行车，
they launched a newspaper together, and of course we all know they invented the first at least successful airplane together. paper together and of course we all know they invented the first at least successful airplane together. And I always assumed that they were just lucky to have such harmony. And yet if you read any of the biographies that have been written about them, if you read their own letters and personal communications, if you read the stories and the anecdotes from people who knew them well, it was very clear that arguing was their default mode and it was almost the family business. And what I think is fascinating about the Wright Brothers is they mastered the ability to have productive task conflicts without it spilling into relationship conflict.
他们一起创办了一份报纸，当然我们都知道他们一起发明了第一架至少是成功的飞机。我一直以为他们只是幸运地拥有这样的和谐。然而，如果你阅读任何关于他们的传记，如果你阅读他们自己的信件和个人通讯，如果你阅读那些了解他们的人的故事和轶事，很明显，争论是他们的默认模式，这几乎是家族生意。我认为关于莱特兄弟最迷人的是，他们掌握了进行富有成效的任务冲突而不让它演变成关系冲突的能力。
It was typical for them when they were trying to invent their airplane to argue for weeks about questions like how do you design a propeller? And they would sometimes even shout for hours back and forth and at one point their sister threatened to leave the house because she just couldn't take it anymore. But they seem to get a kick out of it. They called it scrapping. And they said look, a whole point of an argument is it helps Both people see more clearly if you do it well They never saw an argument as personal The their mechanic used to phrase that that I think about almost every day
当他们试图发明飞机时，争论几周关于如何设计螺旋桨之类的问题对他们来说是很典型的。他们有时甚至会大喊大叫几个小时，有一次他们的妹妹威胁要离开家，因为她实在受不了了。但他们似乎从中得到了乐趣。他们称之为“废料”。他们说，看，争论的全部意义在于它有助于两个人看得更清楚，如果你做得好。他们从不把争论看作是私人的。他们的机械师过去常说的一句话，我几乎每天都会想到，
He said I don't think they really got mad, but they sure got awfully hot and That that to me captures the passion, the energy, the feistyness that goes into, you know, duking out a set of ideas that's really important to you. But not leaving that interaction angry. Now, not all of us have the benefit of having, you know, a sibling, you know, real or metaphorical who can play this role for us. Uh, we don't have a partner, maybe who, who can help us rethink our views. But all of us are often part of organizations and part of teams, or we can be part of organizations and teams that in some ways can play the same role for us. You tell the story of Steve Jobs, the co-founder of Apple, obviously a brilliant
他说，我不认为他们真的生气了，但他们确实变得非常热。对我来说，这捕捉到了那种激情、能量、那种投入到，你知道，争论一套对你非常重要的想法的活力。但不要带着愤怒离开那种互动。现在，我们并非所有人都有幸拥有，你知道，一个兄弟姐妹，你知道，真实的或隐喻的，可以为我们扮演这个角色。呃，我们可能没有一个伴侣，谁，谁能帮助我们重新思考我们的观点。但我们所有人通常都是组织和团队的一部分，或者我们可以成为组织和团队的一部分，在某些方面可以为我们扮演同样的角色。你讲述了史蒂夫·乔布斯的故事，苹果公司的联合创始人，显然是一个天才，
visionary, but he was also famously stubborn. He was also prone to the first instinct fallacy and very nearly came close to not inventing the iPhone. Can you tell me what happened and how Steve's mind got changed? Sure. When you think about your network, we all have a support network. That's usually the highly agreeable people who we know are going to have our back and really lift us up or pick us up when we're down. I think what we overlook is that we also need a challenge network, which is a group of people that we trust to question us, to point out the holes in our thinking, the flaws in our logic, the ways that our decisions might be leading us astray from our goals. And it's not clear to me that Steve Jobs did this intentionally, but he was very lucky
有远见的人，但他也是出了名的固执。他也容易犯第一直觉谬误，并且非常接近没有发明iPhone。你能告诉我发生了什么，史蒂夫的想法是如何改变的吗？当然。当你想到你的网络时，我们都有一个支持网络。那通常是高度随和的人，我们知道他们会支持我们，并在我们低落时真正提升我们或扶起我们。我认为我们忽略的是，我们也需要一个挑战网络，这是一群我们信任的人，他们会质疑我们，指出我们思维中的漏洞，我们逻辑中的缺陷，我们的决定可能导致我们偏离目标的各种方式。我不清楚史蒂夫·乔布斯是否是有意这样做的，但他非常幸运，
to be surrounded with a group of people who played that role of a challenge network for him. What I do all day is meet with teams of people and work on ideas and solve problems to make new products to make new marketing programs, whatever it is. And are people willing to tell you you're wrong? Yeah. I mean other than snarky journalists. I mean people that work for you. Oh yeah. No, we have wonderful arguments. And do you win them all? Oh no, I wish I did. I'll see you in the next one.
被一群扮演他挑战网络角色的人所包围。我整天做的事情就是与团队会面，研究想法并解决问题，以制造新产品，制定新的营销计划，无论是什么。人们愿意告诉你你错了吗？是的。我的意思是，除了尖刻的记者。我的意思是为你工作的人。哦，是的。不，我们有很棒的争论。你赢了所有的争论吗？哦，不，我希望我赢了。下次见。
And he was dead set against making a phone. He complained for years about how smartphones were for the pocket protector crowd. And Apple makes cool products. We don't want to touch that. He could rant for hours at a time about how everybody was beholden to the cell phone carriers and they didn't know how to make
他坚决反对制造手机。他抱怨了多年智能手机是如何为口袋保护者人群准备的。苹果制造酷产品。我们不想碰那个。他可以一次咆哮几个小时，关于每个人是如何受制于手机运营商的，他们不知道如何制造，
an elegant product and sometimes he would even throw his own phone against the wall and shatter it because he was so frustrated with how bad the technology was. Luckily, I think for Apple and for anybody who's a fan of the iPhone or the iPad, he's surrounded himself with brilliant engineers and designers who knew how to get him to think again. You have to be run by ideas, not hierarchy. The best ideas have to win.
一个优雅的产品，有时他甚至会把自己的手机扔到墙上并摔碎，因为他对技术有多糟糕感到非常沮丧。幸运的是，我认为对于苹果公司以及任何iPhone或iPad的粉丝来说，他身边围绕着天才的工程师和设计师，他们知道如何让他重新思考。你必须由想法驱动，而不是等级制度。最好的想法必须获胜。
And a lot of the things that they did as part of his challenge network are things that we've seen people do every day They would plant seeds they would say hey I hear Microsoft is talking about making a phone How ugly do you think that's gonna be and if we ever made one of those what would that look like? They would ask questions like You know hey, we did the iPod. We've already put 20,000 songs in your pocket. What if we put everything in your pocket?
他们作为他的“挑战网络”成员所做的许多事情，正是我们每天都能看到人们在做的事情。他们会播下种子，他们会说：“嘿，我听说微软正在谈论制造一款手机，你觉得它会有多丑？如果我们真的做了一款，它会是什么样子？”他们会问这样的问题：“你知道吗，我们做了iPod，我们已经把两万首歌放进了你的口袋。如果我们把一切都放进你的口袋里会怎样？”
And what they were doing was they were activating his curiosity. If you told him he was wrong, he would immediately go into prosecutor mode, and tear your argument apart. If you told him about your idea, he would preach about his idea. But if you could ask a question that intrigued him and let him realize that he didn't know some things, he might then go out and try to discover them or give you the green light to go and discover them.
他们所做的是在激活他的好奇心。如果你告诉他他错了，他会立即进入“检察官模式”，把你的论点撕得粉碎。如果你告诉他你的想法，他会开始宣扬他的想法。但如果你能问一个让他感兴趣的问题，让他意识到自己有些事情并不了解，他可能就会去尝试探索，或者给你开绿灯去探索。
And those kinds of conversations finally got him to reverse course and make a phone. You've looked at people who are successful negotiators and successful debaters. What are some of the techniques they use that the rest of us might not think to do right off the bat in terms of engaging with an opponent, for example? What are some of the do's and don'ts? Okay. So there's a classic study by Neil Rackerman, colleagues of expert versus
正是这些对话最终让他改变了方针，决定制造一款手机。你观察过那些成功的谈判者和辩论者。对于我们其他人来说，在与对手接触时，有哪些技巧是我们可能不会立刻想到的？有哪些该做和不该做的事？好的。尼尔·拉克曼（Neil Rackerman）和同事们曾对专家与普通谈判者进行过一项经典研究，
average negotiators where they compare what their habits are. And there are a few things that differentiate the experts from the average negotiators. One is they spend a lot more time, both in their planning and in their actual negotiations, thinking about common ground and talking about common ground, saying, we wanna build areas of consensus before we find out where we're opposed. They also ask a lot more questions.
他们比较了各自的习惯。有几点将专家与普通谈判者区分开来。首先，他们在计划和实际谈判中都花了更多时间思考共同点并讨论共同点，他们会说：“我们想在发现分歧之前先建立共识领域。”他们还会提出更多问题。
They'd say, okay, here are two or three possible proposals. What are your reactions to these? What do you like? What do you dislike? And what are your thoughts? And that allowed them to both learn more and again, signal more flexibility as well. I mean, it's so interesting, especially in the political sphere, but certainly not limited to the political sphere, we often think of trying to change someone's opinion with the metaphor
他们会说：“好吧，这里有两三个可能的方案。你对这些有什么反应？你喜欢什么？你不喜欢什么？你有什么想法？”这使他们既能学到更多，又能再次释放出更多的灵活性。我的意思是，这非常有趣，特别是在政治领域，当然不仅限于政治领域，我们经常用“拔河”的隐喻来思考如何改变某人的观点，
of, you know, a tug of war that the harder I pull, the more I can get you off balance, the more likely I am to win. And the model that you're suggesting here is a very different model, you know, model where you're asking a lot of questions, where you're seeking common ground, where you're willing to make concessions, where you're open to figuring out how you yourself might be wrong. That's a very different model
即我拉得越用力，就越能让你失去平衡，我就越有可能获胜。而你在这里建议的模型是一个非常不同的模型，一个你提出很多问题、寻求共同点、愿意做出让步、愿意弄清楚自己可能哪里错了的模型。这是一个非常不同的模型，
and a very different metaphor than a tug of war. It is. This is not the metaphor I would have ever come up with, but there are some psychologists who said said we should think about disagreements less as wars and more as dances And I can't dance At all, I'm so bad at dancing that my wife signed us up for dancing lessons before our wedding and After the second one she gave up I don't have any rhythm. So I wouldn't have thought of dancing but what I like about the dance metaphor is you
也是一个与拔河完全不同的隐喻。确实如此。这不是我能想出来的隐喻，但有些心理学家说，我们应该把分歧看作舞蹈，而不是战争。我根本不会跳舞，我跳得太差了，以至于我妻子在婚礼前给我们报了舞蹈课，但在第二次课后她就放弃了。我没有任何节奏感。所以我不会想到跳舞，但我喜欢舞蹈隐喻的一点是，
know that in a dance your job is to get in sync with your partner and that means if you've both shown up to the dance with an idea about what steps you're gonna take you can't lead all the time and expect your partner to do all of the adjusting. Right, you actually have to be willing to step back and let your partner lead from time to time. And that's what expert negotiators seem to do. It's what great debaters seem to do. And I think it's what all of us can do more when we have polarized conversations. or when we have polarized conversations. You also apply this insight in education. When you think about what teachers are trying to do, teachers are in some ways the whole
你知道在舞蹈中，你的工作是与舞伴保持同步，这意味着如果你们俩都带着自己打算采取的舞步来到舞池，你不能一直领舞，并指望你的舞伴做出所有的调整。对吧，你实际上必须愿意退后一步，让你的舞伴不时地领舞。这就是专家谈判者似乎在做的事情。这也是伟大的辩论者似乎在做的事情。我认为这也是我们在进行两极化对话时可以做得更多的事情。你也将这一见解应用于教育。当你思考老师们在尝试做什么时，老师们在某种程度上，
point of education is to get people to rethink their views, to think more carefully about their positions, to learn. You describe the story of a public school teacher named Ron Berger, who exemplifies this idea. What does Ron do to help people think about what they're doing in new and interesting ways? So one of the things that Ron does is with his first graders, he'll ask them to draw a house. But instead of drawing a house, he says, I want you to draw four different versions of a house. Instead of drawing a house, he says, I want you to draw four different versions of a house. And he's teaching them that just as you wouldn't expect an artist to frame their first draft,
教育的全部意义在于让人们重新思考他们的观点，更仔细地思考他们的立场，去学习。你描述了一位名叫罗恩·伯格（Ron Berger）的公立学校老师的故事，他就是这个理念的典范。罗恩做了什么来帮助人们以新的、有趣的方式思考他们正在做的事情？罗恩所做的事情之一是，他会让一年级的学生画一栋房子。但他不是直接画房子，而是说：“我希望你们画出四个不同版本的房子。”
that the initial work they do is open to being reinterpreted and can evolve and improve over time. And he sets up a whole challenge network in his classroom, where after you do your first draft, they do what's called a critique session, and all the other students are invited to tell you the things that they think are effective and how you can revise and refine it. Who else would add something? A talk, what would you say? About the angle, because not to be mean about the angle is just not exact. Okay, so show me, come on up here, talk. Show me where, what you would ask him to do, slightly differently. And it's not about you, right? It's about the work.
他是在教导他们，就像你不会指望艺术家把他们的第一稿装裱起来一样，他们所做的初步工作是可以被重新诠释的，并且可以随着时间的推移而演变和改进。他在课堂上建立了一个完整的“挑战网络”，在你完成第一稿后，他们会进行所谓的“评论环节”，所有其他学生都被邀请告诉你他们认为有效的地方，以及你如何修改和完善它。还有谁想补充点什么？谈谈，你会怎么说？关于角度，不是为了刻薄，而是因为角度不准确。好的，展示给我看，上来，谈谈。展示给我看，你会要求他做什么，稍微不同一点。这与你无关，对吧？这是关于作品本身。
Everybody's there to try to help you improve it. And we did it. He's good at it. He is so good. And by the end of going through that exercise, what a lot of students will say is they go home and you know, you've got a first grader who's coloring and they insist to their parents that they want to do six or seven drafts because they really want to keep rethinking the way that they've drawn somebody's eyes or the colors
每个人都在那里试图帮助你改进它。我们做到了。他很擅长这个。他太棒了。在完成这个练习后，很多学生会说他们回家后，你知道，一个正在涂色的一年级学生会坚持要求他们的父母让他们画六七个草稿，因为他们真的想不断重新思考他们画眼睛的方式，或者他们在画中碰巧使用的颜色。
that they happen to use in a picture. And what a great way to learn that just because you had a first thought about how to create an idea or how to answer a question, that does not mean that should be your final thought. So it's interesting we've looked at lots of different variations of this idea of the ways in which task conflict sort of spills over into relationship conflict. So very often when we are resistant to change, it's not because of the specific ideas themselves, it's because of the context in which those ideas are located, how the ideas presented to us, what the idea means to us, whether our identities are tied up with the old idea,
这是一个多么好的学习方式啊，仅仅因为你对如何创造一个想法或如何回答一个问题有了第一个想法，并不意味着那应该是你最终的想法。所以很有趣，我们研究了这种“任务冲突”如何演变成“关系冲突”的多种变体。所以很多时候，当我们抵制改变时，并不是因为想法本身，而是因为这些想法所处的环境，想法呈现给我们的方式，这个想法对我们意味着什么，我们的身份是否与旧想法捆绑在一起，
versus the new idea, our general stereotypes, it's all of this larger context that in some ways holds us almost as if it's in concrete, holds us to our pre-existing views. And one of the things that I see you pointing out repeatedly is that in order to get people out of the cycle where they are interpreting everything through the lens of relationship, conflict and instability, is you actually have to start by emphasizing relationship stability. And in the absence of that, task conflict can quickly become interpreted as relationship conflict. Can you talk to me a moment, Adam, about the very important idea of psychological safety
而不是与新想法捆绑在一起，以及我们普遍的刻板印象，所有这些更大的背景在某种程度上像混凝土一样，将我们固定在既有的观点上。我反复看到你指出的一点是，为了让人们摆脱那种通过关系冲突和不稳定的视角来解读一切的循环，你实际上必须从强调关系稳定性开始。在缺乏这种稳定性的情况下，任务冲突很快就会被解读为关系冲突。亚当，你能和我谈谈“心理安全感”这个非常重要的概念吗？
and how psychological safety is connected with getting teams to think more creatively, more innovatively, and also engage in productive task conflict. Psychological safety is, as Amy Edmondson and Bill Conn and other researchers have defined it, it's the belief that you can take a risk without being punished or penalized. And it's really founded on a culture of trust and respect, where people will say, look, if I want to point out a problem, or I have a concern that I might want to raise, or if I think someone needs to rethink a decision they've made, or a judgment that they've landed at,
以及心理安全感如何与让团队进行更具创造性、更具创新性的思考，并参与富有成效的任务冲突联系在一起？正如艾米·埃德蒙森（Amy Edmondson）、比尔·康（Bill Conn）和其他研究人员所定义的那样，心理安全感是一种信念，即你可以冒险而不会受到惩罚或处罚。它真正建立在信任和尊重的文化之上，人们会说：“看，如果我想指出一个问题，或者我有一个想提出的担忧，或者如果我认为有人需要重新思考他们做出的决定，或者他们得出的判断，
that I can bring that up without having to worry that they're going to bite my head off. And we know that psychological safety is one of the foundations of building a learning culture and making it easy for people to rethink things. Because we've seen this in studies of hospitals, for example, that when teams have psychological safety, they actually admit the errors that they've made, and then everyone else can learn from them and rethink their routines and practices. Whereas if they lack psychological safety, people are motivated to hide their mistakes,
我可以提出来，而不必担心他们会对我大发雷霆。”我们知道，心理安全感是建立学习文化和让人们更容易重新思考事物的基石之一。因为我们在医院的研究中看到了这一点，例如，当团队拥有心理安全感时，他们实际上会承认自己犯的错误，然后其他人可以从中学习，并重新思考他们的常规和做法。而如果他们缺乏心理安全感，人们就会有动力去隐藏错误，
and then they repeat them, and no one else ends up rethinking the way that they're operating either. And so I think there's great value in creating psychological safety. I'd say it's easier said than done for a lot of people. Amy Edminton is quick to point out that psychological safety is not about being nice
然后他们会重复这些错误，其他人最终也不会重新思考他们的运作方式。所以我认为创造心理安全感非常有价值。我想说，对很多人来说，这说起来容易做起来难。艾米·埃德蒙森很快指出，心理安全感并不是关于表现得友善
or having low standards. We actually need psychological safety with accountability. We can have high expectations for people, but also give them the freedom and permission to rethink some of even what we might have called best practices. I have to say that when I look out at the culture at them, when I look at sort of the culture of conversation on social media in our political sphere, you know, on cable TV. I don't see an environment that is rich in psychological safety.
或降低标准。我们实际上需要的是带有问责制的心理安全感。我们可以对人们有很高的期望，但也要给他们自由和许可去重新思考一些我们可能称之为“最佳实践”的东西。我必须说，当我审视当下的文化时，当我审视社交媒体、政治领域、有线电视上的对话文化时，我并没有看到一个充满心理安全感的环境。
I don't see an environment where you're rewarded for being nuanced and for rethinking your views and admitting when you're wrong. In fact, if anything, the incentives are lined up exactly in the opposite direction. Sadly, I think that's become the norm. I do think though there are some steps we can take to have more thoughtful conversations with the strangers that we love to preach at and prosecute. We can be aware of what psychologists call a solution aversion. The idea behind solution aversion is that if you propose a way to fix a problem and people don't like your solution,
我没有看到一个因为细致入微、重新思考观点并承认错误而受到奖励的环境。事实上，如果有的话，激励机制正好朝着相反的方向排列。可悲的是，我认为这已经成为常态。但我确实认为，我们可以采取一些步骤，与我们喜欢说教和起诉的陌生人进行更深思熟虑的对话。我们可以意识到心理学家所说的“解决方案厌恶”。解决方案厌恶背后的想法是，如果你提出一种解决问题的方法，而人们不喜欢你的解决方案，
they often reject not only the solution but also the problem in the first place. So let's say with climate change for example, if you say, well, we need a whole bunch of companies to reduce their emissions and you're talking to somebody who's a staunch free market conservative. They're not necessarily going to like that idea and so their motivation then is to deny the existence of the climate problem in the first place. And I think we should be really cautious about jumping to solutions. We would be better off saying, Hey, I'm aware that there are some problems when it comes to climate change. And I would love to hear your ideas about the different
他们往往不仅拒绝解决方案，还会首先拒绝承认问题本身。所以，以气候变化为例，如果你说：“好吧，我们需要一大批公司减少排放”，而你正在和一个坚定的自由市场保守派交谈。他们不一定会喜欢这个想法，所以他们的动机就是首先否认气候问题的存在。我认为我们应该非常谨慎，不要急于跳到解决方案上。如果我们说：“嘿，我知道在气候变化方面存在一些问题，我很想听听你对我们解决这些问题的不同可能方法的想法”，这样会更好。
possible ways that we could solve them. We shouldn't spend all this time talking about why my solution is right or why your view that climate change isn't an issue is wrong. Instead I should say, well given your views about what we should do on climate policy, how would your proposed solutions work and how would you implement them? And when you ask those how questions, something really intriguing happens. Psychologists call it the illusion of explanatory depth. And it's the idea that we think we understand
我们不应该花所有时间谈论为什么我的解决方案是正确的，或者为什么你认为气候变化不是一个问题的观点是错误的。相反，我应该说：“好吧，鉴于你对我们在气候政策上应该做什么的看法，你提出的解决方案将如何运作，你将如何实施它们？”当你问这些“如何”的问题时，一些非常有趣的事情发生了。心理学家称之为“解释深度的错觉”。这就是我们认为我们理解
complex systems much better than we actually do. And the best way to make us a little bit more intellectually humble, curious, nuanced, more doubting, less dogmatic, is to ask us to explain those very systems and their impact. And so if you try to walk me through all of the effects of a greenhouse gas emissions program,
复杂系统的程度远比我们实际理解的要好。而让我们变得更谦逊、更好奇、更细致、更怀疑、更少教条的最好方法，就是要求我们解释这些系统及其影响。所以如果你试着引导我了解温室气体减排计划的所有影响，
you quickly realize there are a lot of things you don't know. And empirically that tends to lead you to moderate your views. You become less extreme. You become more open-minded. And we have a more civil dialogue. So I want to take a moment and channel Adam Grant in the next question I'm asking Adam Grant. And I want to try and rethink some of the things that we have said in the conversation today. You know, we all know the iPhone was a hit. So we can work backwards and deduce that Steve Jobs was right to listen to his engineers. But there's also some risk in this kind of backward induction.
你很快就会意识到有很多事情你并不知道。从经验上看，这往往会引导你缓和自己的观点。你变得不那么极端。你变得更开放。我们有了更文明的对话。所以我想花点时间，在接下来的问题中引导亚当·格兰特（Adam Grant）。我想尝试重新思考我们在今天的对话中所说的一些事情。你知道，我们都知道iPhone是一个热门产品。所以我们可以倒推并推断史蒂夫·乔布斯听取他的工程师的意见是正确的。但这种倒推也存在一些风险。
Sometimes it might be possible that inflexibility is actually the right answer. You know, some of history's greatest leaders have been relatively inflexibility is actually the right answer. You know, some of history's greatest leaders have been relatively inflexible. You know, think about Winston Churchill facing down, you know, Adolf Hitler. Even think of, you know, people like Mahatma Gandhi, you know, very singular focused in terms of what they were doing,
有时，不灵活性实际上可能是正确的答案。你知道，历史上一些最伟大的领导者相对来说是不灵活的。你知道，想想温斯顿·丘吉尔面对阿道夫·希特勒。甚至想想像圣雄甘地这样的人，你知道，在他们所做的事情上非常单一地专注，
very unwilling to reconsider, sort of, the rightness of their views. Now, clearly, you know, inflexibility is also associated with some of the worst leaders in history, but are there times when, in fact, second guessing can lead to dissension, to dithering, maybe even to defeat? I think those are great examples,
非常不愿意重新考虑他们观点的正确性。现在，显然，你知道，不灵活性也与历史上一些最糟糕的领导者联系在一起，但有没有时候，事实上，事后怀疑会导致异议、犹豫不决，甚至导致失败？我认为这些都是很好的例子，
and I think you're right. Right, what's the saying that every great truth has an opposite truth? Yeah. So, flexibilities have hurt virtue, so is persistence. And I think that the art, much more than science, is figuring out when to say the course and when to shift gears.
而且我认为你是对的。对吧，那句谚语怎么说来着，每一个伟大的真理都有一个相反的真理？是的。所以，灵活性是一种美德，坚持也是。我认为，比起科学，这更是一门艺术，即弄清楚何时坚持到底，何时改变方向。
I don't think that being open to rethinking means you always have to change your mind. So if you're Churchill, the goal of beating Hitler, definitely don't want you to rethink that. I do want you though to be open to different strategies, right? Because I might find out that their strategy has changed. And so my needs to evolve too. And I think that what that means is we can be pretty steadfast in our principles and
我不认为对重新思考持开放态度意味着你必须总是改变主意。所以如果你是丘吉尔，打败希特勒的目标，绝对不希望你重新思考。但我确实希望你对不同的策略持开放态度，对吧？因为我可能会发现他们的策略已经改变了。所以我的策略也需要演变。我认为这意味着我们可以在原则和
our overarching goals and very flexible in finding the right ways to achieve those goals or live those principles. You know, as I was reading your book Adam, I was thinking about this proverb, I don't remember where I read this, but it said that if you want to walk fast, you should walk alone, but if you want to walk far, you should walk together. And I'm wondering if that's possible that that second-guessing and rethinking might in fact have short-term costs, but long-term benefits. I would say that's an astute observation.
总体目标上相当坚定，而在寻找实现这些目标或践行这些原则的正确方法上非常灵活。你知道，当我读你的书时，亚当，我在想这句谚语，我不记得在哪里读到的了，但它说如果你想走得快，你应该独自走，但如果你想走得远，你应该一起走。我想知道，事后怀疑和重新思考是否可能确实有短期成本，但有长期利益。我会说这是一个敏锐的观察。
I think rethinking... it doesn't have to be slow, but it often slows us down. I worry that we spend too much of our time listening to people who think fast and shallow, and not enough time paying attention to people who think slow and deep. And I might even go further and say, I think we need to become people sometimes who think slow and deep, which is a, yeah, I guess a reinforcement of so much of what Danny Conneman has spent his career studying. But I think that there are also ways to accelerate our rethinking. Because it would be very tempting to say, okay, you know, in a lot of situations, what we need to do is we just need to slow down, we need to pause, we need to give our self a chance to come up with a second opinion and third opinions. And yeah, I
我认为重新思考……它不一定非要很慢，但它确实经常让我们慢下来。我担心我们花太多时间听那些思考得快而浅的人，而没有花足够的时间关注那些思考得慢而深的人。我甚至可以更进一步说，我认为我们有时需要成为思考得慢而深的人，这在某种程度上是对丹尼·卡尼曼（Danny Kahneman）职业生涯所研究内容的强化。但我认为也有一些方法可以加速我们的重新思考。因为说“好吧，你知道，在很多情况下，我们需要做的是慢下来，我们需要暂停，我们需要给自己一个机会去提出第二意见和第三意见”是非常诱人的。是的，我
think slowing down helps with that. But there's no reason why we can't in the moment say, okay, I'm about to make a decision. I have a clear plan about what I want my career to be or I have an idea about what city I want to live in. And let me take five minutes and just think about all the reasons why that plan might be wrong, not just the reasons it might be right. Let me reach out to somebody in my challenge network and ask them, can you see some holes in my reasoning? Is there any way that I might regret this decision?
认为慢下来对此有帮助。但没有理由我们不能在当下说：“好吧，我正要做出一个决定。我对我的职业生涯想要什么有一个明确的计划，或者我对我想住哪个城市有一个想法。让我花五分钟时间，只思考这个计划可能错误的所有原因，而不仅仅是它可能正确的原因。让我联系一下我挑战网络中的某个人，问问他们：你能看出我推理中的漏洞吗？我有什么可能会后悔这个决定吗？”
And that can be a quick reconsideration process. I cannot tell you, Shankar, how many leaders told me they would never let their people work remote and are now questioning whether they should even have a physical office. I think it's unfortunate that we only did that rethinking when we were forced to, and I think we could take the initiative to do it more deliberately, more proactively, as opposed to waiting until we have no other choice. Adam Grant is the author of Think Again, the power of knowing what you don't know. Adam, thank you for joining me today on Hidden Brain.
这可以是一个快速的重新考虑过程。我无法告诉你，尚卡尔（Shankar），有多少领导者告诉我他们永远不会让员工远程工作，而现在却在质疑他们是否应该拥有一个实体办公室。我认为不幸的是，我们只有在被迫时才进行那种重新思考，我认为我们可以主动采取行动，更刻意、更主动地去做，而不是等到别无选择。亚当·格兰特是《重新思考》（Think Again）一书的作者，该书探讨了了解你所不知道的事物的力量。亚当，感谢你今天加入“隐藏的大脑”（Hidden Brain）。
Thank you, Shocker. This was such a delight. Hidden Brain is produced by Hidden Brain Media. Our audio production team includes Bridget McCarthy, Annie Murphy Paul, Laura Quarelle, Kristen Wong, Ryan Katz, Autumn Barnes, and Andrew Chadwick. Tara Boyle is our executive producer. I'm Hidden Brain's executive editor. For today's Anson Hero, return the mic over to you, our listeners, with a story from our show, My Anson Hero. Today's Myan Sanghiro is brought to you by Anstar. Anstar advisors are now with you everywhere on the app, in your car, and at home.
谢谢你，尚卡尔。这真是太令人愉快了。“隐藏的大脑”由“隐藏的大脑媒体”制作。我们的音频制作团队包括布里奇特·麦卡锡（Bridget McCarthy）、安妮·墨菲·保罗（Annie Murphy Paul）、劳拉·夸雷尔（Laura Quarelle）、克里斯汀·王（Kristen Wong）、瑞安·卡茨（Ryan Katz）、奥特姆·巴恩斯（Autumn Barnes）和安德鲁·查德威克（Andrew Chadwick）。塔拉·博伊尔（Tara Boyle）是我们的执行制片人。我是“隐藏的大脑”的执行编辑。对于今天的“安森英雄”（Anson Hero），我们将话筒交还给你们，我们的听众，分享我们节目中的一个故事，我的“安森英雄”。今天的“我的安森英雄”由安吉星（OnStar）为您呈现。安吉星顾问现在通过应用程序、在您的车里和家里随时陪伴着您。
Our story comes from Lauren Vaya-Dares. After graduating from college, Lauren moved to Central America for six years. While there, she worked at an international aid organization, got her master's degree, and fell in love with a man named Pedro. And we got pregnant. So we decided to take a beach trip for a weekend to the nearest beach, was about three hours away. We were at the beach, it was a beautiful day. There were lots of people out and about, and lots of surfers and swimmers, and we decided to go ahead and get in the water.
我们的故事来自劳伦·瓦亚-达雷斯（Lauren Vaya-Dares）。大学毕业后，劳伦搬到中美洲住了六年。在那里，她在一个国际援助组织工作，获得了硕士学位，并爱上了一个名叫佩德罗（Pedro）的男人。我们怀孕了。所以我们决定周末去最近的海滩进行一次海滩旅行，大约三个小时的路程。我们在海滩上，那是一个美丽的日子。外面有很多人，有很多冲浪者和游泳者，我们决定下水。
And what I didn't know about Pedro Beck then is that he was not a strong swimmer. We got in pretty cautiously, then then before you knew it, we weren't touching the bottom. We turned around, and we're pretty far from where we started. I'm treading water, just fine. And I noticed that Pedro's sort of struggling a little bit. And here I am, five months pregnant, about a hundred meters from the shoreline. And my fiancé now can't swim, and he's starting to really struggle.
我当时不知道的是，佩德罗并不擅长游泳。我们非常谨慎地进入水中，然后不知不觉中，我们就踩不到底了。我们转过身，发现离出发的地方已经很远了。我踩水踩得很好。我注意到佩德罗有点挣扎。而我，怀孕五个月，离岸边大约一百米。我现在的未婚夫不会游泳，他开始真正挣扎了。
So my life starts flashing before my eyes, and I'm thinking we're all going to drown. We were far away from the shore, and I wouldn't be able to take him in. Out of nowhere comes a surfer on his board. Like out of nowhere, he wasn't around when we had started swimming. We weren't close to anybody when, you know, at the place we had gotten the water. But this surfer comes up and says, hey, do you guys need help? Because he saw a struggling. And we said, Yes, yes, please. He had us grab onto his board and started pedaling towards the shore. We took us a while to get in, but we came up on shore. We were exhausted
所以我的生活开始在我眼前闪现，我想我们都要淹死了。我们离岸边很远，我无法带他回去。突然，一个冲浪者出现在他的冲浪板上。就像凭空出现一样，我们开始游泳时他并不在附近。我们下水的地方附近也没有任何人。但这个冲浪者走过来问：“嘿，你们需要帮助吗？”因为他看到了挣扎。我们说：“是的，是的，请。”他让我们抓住他的冲浪板，开始向岸边划去。我们花了一段时间才上岸，但我们上岸了。我们精疲力竭，
and shocked that we were even still alive. And we said thank you to this guy, and then he walked away. And I think back to that moment often, and I regret not asking him his name. I always think had I asked him his name, my first born son would have been named after him. Because he not only saved our lives, the two of us, but he saved our future family. Lauren Viadaris lives in Tucson, Arizona. She and Pedro have two children with a third baby on the way. This segment was brought to you by OnStar. OnStar believes everyone
并为我们竟然还活着而感到震惊。我们向这个人道谢，然后他走开了。我经常回想起那一刻，我很后悔没有问他的名字。我总是想，如果我问了他的名字，我的第一个儿子就会以他的名字命名。因为他不仅救了我们的命，我们两个人的命，他还救了我们未来的家庭。劳伦·瓦亚-达雷斯住在亚利桑那州的图森市。她和佩德罗有两个孩子，第三个孩子也即将出生。本片段由安吉星为您呈现。安吉星相信每个人
has the right to feel safe everywhere. That's why their emergency advisors are now available to help not only in the car but wherever you are, on your phone, in your car, and at home. Onster. Be safe out there. If you're a fan of the show, if you feel we have given you ideas that have been useful in your life, please help us make more episodes like this. Go to support.hiddenbrain.org. Again, that support.hiddenbrain.org and show us that you have our back. I'm Shankar Vedantam. See you soon.
都有权在任何地方感到安全。这就是为什么他们的紧急顾问现在不仅可以在车里提供帮助，无论您在哪里，在您的手机上、车里和家里，他们都能提供帮助。安吉星。注意安全。如果你是节目的粉丝，如果你觉得我们提供的想法对你的生活有用，请帮助我们制作更多这样的剧集。请访问 support.hiddenbrain.org。再次强调，是 support.hiddenbrain.org，向我们展示你们的支持。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆（Shankar Vedantam）。很快再见。
you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
你 本集暂无评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。